i hold in my hand the overtime questions
cis boom boom oh no that's karnak i'm
sorry
you're the guy you know that how do you
know that you're the same age but you
remember that specific joke it's the
best one it is the best one right should
we tell them what it is go ahead car
neck
you want to be ed
sisboomba what is the sound of an
exploding shape
no you're ed you repeat it and then
it doesn't work and then i
what is
this here are the questions what what do
you think why do you think biden is
polling so poorly with female voters the
same group who are instrumental to his
win in 2020. i've read that too that his
numbers are way down among uh females
well i think i think college-educated
women have moved a little bit toward him
but did i mention the schools were
closed for a year that's what it is that
it was a problem for a lot of moms and
those moms got real pissed off
moms are going to save the world
do you have any personal experience with
this
okay
i'm getting that i'm just amazing the
way i just i'm almost psychic very
intuitive yes uh but you think that's
what i think it's also inflation i think
people moms are in the supermarket and
they're going down the aisle and going
wow the chicken is 25
or whatever a chicken is i don't know
it's getting there
i don't live with someone who comes home
and says chicken it's 25 dollars
yes amber heard i hear it is available
and uh
that was that is some nasty [ __ ] i mean
yes
you have thoughts on that do you like
who do you think one of them is lying
more than the other i had assumed the
poop was his so when it was hers that
blew my mind
like there's no winner here he just
you just figured johnny depp yeah poop
in the bed it seemed to fit the whole
profile that was being established and
when she just jumped on there i thought
wow well i like that he specified that
the dogs who were blamed for the poop
yes are their little teacup dogs he's
like that was not
from the dog
i think that is that's evidence yeah
very valid argument yes i think i think
that should be
exhibit a um
the biden administration has been
referring to gas price increases as
putin price hikes do you think this is a
fair characterization well that's the
inflation issue
look it's worth a try
i mean but people well it does have
something to do yes it has something to
do with it but people's memories go back
further than the past two months right
and they know that that prices were
going up before that and
kids had to stay home
[Laughter]
i'm gonna beat you too at this time
[ __ ] kids they were homies [ __ ]
kids were climbing up my back every day
let it out i love them
[Laughter]
no i think it a lot of eyes opened up i
think about teachers and kids because it
was like oh maybe the teacher isn't the
problem maybe my kid is a little [ __ ]
[Applause]
is there anything with that
[Applause]
okay
54 of americans don't think biden is
tough enough on putin uh how do you
think trump would have handled the
current situation interesting question
how do you think trump would i think
he'd be the love letter yeah
very strong leader he's a very strong
leader he's taking strong strong
measures in ukraine
yeah it's interesting i mean because we
you never really can tell with trump
because as i pointed out many times he's
stupid and he's crazy
we've had crazy and we've had stupid
he's stupid and he's crazy and i think
he would say he would say what you said
some version of kissing
ass
and but then he'd also like you know do
some drone shot on somebody and be like
look at that
i mean
right
right this this was his way right okay
all right thank you very much everybody
i appreciate you being here
you